foreign
[Music]
this year for Valentine's Day we decided
to throw a lonely hearts party for all
of our single friends sometimes when
we're around them we feel a little
guilty for having found each other like
we're waving our love in their faces
it's got to be a better way of saying
that anyway it was supposed to be an
elegant affair
Ogle me
Showtime put the cat away okay yeah
right oh and Mitchell please hey please
try to have fun tonight I always have
fun no I know you're great at stay at
home fun and sit on the couch fun but
this is party fun and sometimes okay
this is not fun get the door
thank you
fine I will show you some fun
things got a little hazy after that
hello
um yeah hi Dad
no no I'm up I am up yeah bring her by
at any time
okay good night
oh Cam
oh God that was some party last night
yeah well I'm just glad you made it home
safely made a I don't even remember
leaving the party oh I think I got a
little tipsy Tipsy you were like all of
the Mad Men oh no no don't make it out
like I did a lot of crazy out of control
I was hoping I dreamed that
come on like like you've never had a few
cocktails inside a cat pink with cherry
Kool-Aid okay well is there anything
else you need to tell me about not that
I remember
I'm remembering this oh my gosh Mitchell
are these Burton Dottie Winchell's
Christmas decorations how could you they
never take them down okay I was doing
the whole neighborhood a favor
oh God cam I you know I think I think
they're pictures I remember pepper and
longinus were the oh okay
oh my gosh those poor reindeer oh it
seems that Prancer is the bell of the
ball no surprise there oh you must be
Vixen okay okay not funny Mitchell look
at this place what were you thinking
okay Camp I yes I went a little nuts all
right I I'm sorry but I didn't do
anything that can't be undone hey
roomies
hey thank you so much for letting me
move in here
um yes could you excuse us for just a a
moment Dylan yeah take as much time as
you need it's your house I just live
here now
okay did I tell him that he could live
with us obviously oh my God was he even
at our party yes he's been driving a
limousine for some company and Jamarcus
hired him for the night and now he lives
here are you all caught up there I don't
I don't remember any of this well let's
create a new memory one where you tell
him he can't live here
can I say one short thing I came to this
house a broken man after my mom threw me
out for her new boyfriend and then I
found out I was getting let go from the
limo company the same night hilly goes
to a party without me so I had nothing
and no one
and then you
okay come on tell him let him finish I'm
sorry I mean
gay dudes have always been nice to me I
mean super nice but nothing like this I
guess what I'm trying to say is oh my
God he's gonna sing
so many years living life underwater
came up for air in the room of your
daughter
and never knew I would find my answer in
my ex-girlfriend's uncle's house with
the tiny Pink Panther
[Music]
I'm sorry oh gosh okay this is this is
really hard for me to say but we just
cannot
not wash our cats
I'm sorry
And yet when I did that drunk not a
scratch
oh my gosh this place is cleaner than
when we moved in I don't know best house
guest ever no we are not keeping him
do you think he took the Christmas
decorations back to the winchells oh
well I think he thinks he did what okay
yeah Dylan Dylan
[Applause]
hello hey guys I'm up here yeah hi
listen Dylan those decorations were on
the yard of that house
Oh No Good Deed huh yeah well
hey
I can see your house from here oh oh
geez are you kidding me this day oh my
God I hate myself right now what kind of
monster throws an injured innocent onto
the street you can't live here get out
Lily Lily
he's right everyone says it I need to
stop running from conflict it's time to
be a big boy and patch things up and
move back in with my mom
I'll get my things okay sorry yeah
[Music]